>>> CANADA COULD DECIDE ANY DAY
NOW IF IT WILL REOPEN ITS U.S.
BORDER OR EXTEND THE MORE THAN
YEAR-LONG SHUTDOWN BECAUSE OF
THE CONTINUING PANDEMIC.
POINT ROBERTS WASHINGTON IN
PARTICULAR HAS BEEN HARD HIT BY
THE CLOSURE.
IT'S ON A PENINSULA CONNECTED TO
CANADA AND SEPARATED FROM THE
U.S. BY THE PACIFIC OCEAN EVEN
THOUGH IT'S ONLY HAD ONE COVID
CASE, MANY ARE WORRIED THAT
POINT ROBERTS COULD TURN INTO A
COVID GHOST TOWN.
KRIS VAN CLEAVE SHOWS US WHY.
>>> HI.
>> Reporter: THIS IS HOW PAMELA
ROBERTSON SEES FAMILY DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> Reporter: SIX FEET APART AND
A COUNTRY AWAY.
PAMELA IN THE U.S., HER DAUGHTER
IN CANADA.
SEPARATED BY A BORDER THAT
REMAINS CLOSED TO ALL BUT
ESSENTIAL TRAVEL, EVEN IF THE
BORDER IS JUST A YELLOW CONCRETE
BARRIER.
>> AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED IT'S
ESSENTIAL, AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED THEY SHOULD LET ME IN.
>> Reporter: BUT PAMELA WAS
TURNED AWAY BY CANADIAN BORDER
GUARDS WHEN SHE TRIED TO SEE HER
DENTIST ABOUT AN ABSCESS, AN
INFECTION THAT CAUSED THE SIDE
OF HER FACE TO SWELL AND COULD
TURN INTO A SERIOUS HEALTH RISK
IF LEFT UNTREATED.
>> I ASKED HIM WHAT WAS
ESSENTIAL IN THEIR EYES, AND HE
SAID TO ME, UNFORTUNATELY YOU
HAVE TO BE LIKE DYING.
>> Reporter: SHE LIVES IN POINT
ROBERTS, A SMALL PICTURESQUE
SEASIDE TOWN OF ABOUT 1,100 WITH
SWEEPING VIEWS.
PRE-COVID IT WOULD QUADRUPLE IN
SIZE EVERY SUMMER AS CANADIANS
FLOCK SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
POINT ROBERTS IS A BIT OF A
GEOGRAPHICAL ODDITY, LYING JUST
SOUTH OF THE 49th PARALLEL, IT
IS A U.S. EX-CLAF, PART OF
WASHINGTON STATE BUT COMPLETELY
DISCONNECTED FROM THE U.S.
SO TO GET TO A DENTIST, PAMELA
HAS TO CROSS THE BORDER.
ARE YOU FRUSTRATED, ARE YOU
ANGRY?
>> I CAN'T BE ANGRY BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THE COUNTRY IS TRYING
THEIR BEST TO KEEP COVID AT BAY.
I'M JUST FRUSTRATED WITH THE
SYSTEM.
>> Reporter: WHILE COVID REMAINS
A MAJOR CONCERN IN NEIGHBORING
BRITISH COLUMBIA, POINT ROBERTS
HAS HAD ONLY ONE CASE IN MORE
THAN A YEAR.
STILL, THIS SMALL COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN LOCKED OUT OF ESSENTIAL
NEEDS.
THERE'S NO FULL-TIME DOCTOR,
THERE'S NO DENTIST, THERE'S NO
VETERINARIAN, THERE'S NOT EVEN A
PHARMACY.
YOU CAN SEE WHY THE PEOPLE WHO
CALL POINT ROBERTS HOME ARE
WORRIED IT COULD BECOME A COVID
GHOST TOWN.
>> I HAD SIX CUSTOMERS ON
SUNDAY.
>> Reporter: HOW DOES THAT
COMPARE TO A NORMAL SUNDAY
BEFORE COVID?
>> I WOULD HAVE UPWARDS OF 30,
40, 60 --
>> Reporter: TAMRA HANSEN OWNS
THE SALTWATER CAFE, THE ONLY
OPEN RESTAURANT AROUND.
95% OF HER BUSINESS IS CANADIANS
COMING FURTHER VACATION OR
CROSSING THE BORDER FOR LOWER
PRICES ON FOOD AND GAS.
AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR WITH
VIRTUALLY NOW CUSTOMERS, SHE'S
BACK OPEN IN HOPES OF QUALIFYING
FOR ANOTHER PPP LOAN TO TRY TO
STAY AFLOAT UNTIL THE BORDER
REOPENS EVEN THOUGH THE CAFE IS
UNDER WATER EVERY DAY ITS DOORS
ARE OPEN.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT HAVING TO
CLOSE THE BUSINESS AND WALK
AWAY?
>> YES, I DO.
I REALLY, YOU KNOW, I WAS JUST
WORKING UP TO SOME OF MY BEST
YEARS HERE.
SO I DO WORRY.
>> Reporter: VIRTUALLY ALL POINT
ROBERTS RESIDENTS ARE EXPECTED
TO BE VACCINATED BY THE END OF
THE MONTH.
BUT CANADIAN OFFICIALS AREN'T
BUDGING ON THE BORDER ISSUE
DESPITE ALLOWING RESIDENTS FROM
ANOTHER U.S. EXCLAVE IN ALASKA
EASY ENTRANCE.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR THE MINISTER
OF PUBLIC SAFETY SAYS, "WE
RECOGNIZE THE UNIQUE POSITION
AND HARDSHIPS FACED BY THE
PEOPLE OF POINT ROBERTS."
BUT CONGRESSMAN SUZAN DELBENE
SAYS THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
IF THIS WAS HAPPENING IN ALMOST
ANY OTHER CITY IN THE U.S.,
PEOPLE WOULD LOSE THEIR MINDS.
>> AND FOLKS SHOULD BE.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE THAT MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND ALLOW PEOPLE IN POINT
ROBERTS TO MOVE.
>> Reporter: SO CONGRESSWOMAN,
WHY IS IT SO HARD TO GET THAT
DONE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I WISH I COULD TELL YOU BECAUSE
I'M GOING TO KEEP FIGHTING.
>> Reporter: PAMELA ROBERTSON
FINALLY GOT ACROSS THE BORDER
BUT ONLY AFTER AGREEING TO
QUARANTINE FOR TWO WEEKS UNDER
THE THREAT OF ARREST.
WORTH IT TO FINALLY SEE HER
DENTIST AND HUG HER GRANDKIDS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OVER A
YEAR.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING," KRIS VAN
CLEAVE, POINT ROBERTS,
WASHINGTON.
>> NEVER THOUGHT YOU'D BE THAT
DESPERATE TO GET TO THE DENTIST.
I UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW.
>> WHAT A CRAZY -- THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT WITH DR. FAUCI.
PEOPLE ARE JUST NOT ALWAYS CLEAR
ON WHAT IS PRACTICAL AND COMMON
SENSE AS WE START TO COME OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC.
IT'S REALLY TOUGH.
SURREAL.
>> YEAH.
BEAUTIFUL TOWN, BUT CLEARLY IN A
GEOGRAPHIC DILEMMA.
>> RIGHT.
>> AS WE COME OUT OF IT, THERE